-You guys,
our first guest tonight
is an Emmy award-winning
comedian.
You know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and from the Netflix series,
"Big Mouth."
Please welcome back to the show,
our very good friend,
John Mulaney!
♪♪♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
-Center of this?
Here?
-Oh, you're back!
-This is okay?
-This is okay.
-Cool. All right. Hey, man
-It's so good to see you.
-Good to see you.
-Congratulations on hostin
"SNL" again.
-Thank you very much.
It was really, really fun.
A very magical evening.
-That's good to hear, because,
you know, I would worry that
a lot of the magic
is out of there
because less audience.
But you still had a great time
-There was a really
enthusiastic, wonderful,
hot audience that we could
tell was going to be great
right before the live show
started.
Loren came in my dressing room
and he said,
"They're a really hot crowd.
and that's not said there often.
-No.
-Things that jinx things are -
I mean, things aren't said
there, period.
So jinxes especially.
They said they were
a really hot crowd.
He goes, "There is a whole group
that's dressed as mimes."
And I said, "Well, you know,
mimes are silent."
And he went,
"Well, yeah, but not tonight."
[ Laughter ]
I got a standing "O" from
the mimes.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-Beginning or end?
-Beginning.
I felt really good about it.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-Because, again,
it should be noted this wa
Halloween.
-It was Halloween --
-It's very rare to have a "SNL
on Halloween.
-What if we didn't note it
That would've been fun to just
keep talking about
how there were mimes there
What else is weird
that we're not mentioning?
I can't think.
-It's a great coat, John.
-It's, um, making me so happy.
-Yeah, because --
Well, there is a story
behind it.
-This is a coat worn by --
Oh, there's people.
This is a coat --
Hey, Shoemaker.
This is a coat.
This was the coat
that Julian Casablancas
of The Strokes wore on stage
on "SNL" on Saturday.
-Yeah.
-And when we were shooting
promos, he had on a really coo
Knicks jacket.
I said, "That's a cool jacket.
I gotta get that jacket."
I said that out loud
knowing I --
you know rock stars have clothes
you're like,
"I'm never in my life gonn
see those clothes."
Like, "I'm never going to walk
into the store
where they sell those clothes.
So I said that out loud
thinking maybe he would tell m
where I get the jacket.
-Yeah.
-But that didn't happen.
That's all right.
So after the show,
he came in to my dressing room
He's like,
"So you want a jacket?"
And he gave me this one,
and he gave me a leather jacket.
I mean, this is like --
There is nothing I can do
with this,
but, like, I like -- there i
nothing, but I enjoy it so much.
-It's really good.
-It's so meant for like
a lead singer.
-Yeah, yeah, that's right.
You're right.
-Even me doing a lead singer
is bad.
-See, even that, though,
but when you do that, the coat
all of the sudden comes alive.
-Yeah?
-When you stand like
John Mulaney, there is nothing
happening in that coat.
-Coat or no coat,
there is nothing happening
But I got home, and I was
looking in the pockets,
and I found these.
-Oh, man.
-So I texted him a photo.
I said, "Hey, you left these."
Do you want me to have someone
drop them off?
You know rock stars,
they're very meticulous.
"I'll be right over."
He went, "You keep them, man."
So I just looked in the mirror
Saturday night, you know,
just came home, so thrille
with the show,
so happy to be back here.
And then just to like come down,
I just stood and stared at
myself in the mirror like this
I was so happy.
-You -- it's amazing
how much younger the glasses
make you look.
Because then, you look lik
a kid in a teen movie.
Like it's his first time
at a party.
-Right, right.
But he does computers.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Right. Right.
I know who you're talk about
The glasses bespeak
of computers.
-Yeah.
-Like Whistler in "Sneakers.
-There you go.
-Sure.
Good thing we don't have
an audience here
or they would be going nut
at that reference.
[ Laughter ]
They'd be yelling out thei
favorite "Sneakers" character.
-"Sneakers" holds up.
-It holds up really well
because it's good
and it's about the Internet,
but it's not like "The Net."
-Right.
-Or the movie "Disclosure"
where they're sucked into
a CD-ROM at the end.
Those kind of got them wrong
the future.
-"Sneakers" was kind of
on the money.
-I'd pretty much say "sneakers
in terms of your, like,
Poitier, Robert Redford,
Dan Aykroyd, River Phoenix
David Strathairn.
-Is it Rene Russo?
-No. It's, uh, um...
-Oh, it's --
-Mary.
-From "Battlestar Galactica.
-Let's edit it like we know he
name.
-Yeah.
-It's Mary McDonald?
-Mary McDonnell.
-Yeah, and Mary McDonald.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
So I am realizing --
-That will trim well.
-Yeah, well,
'cause it's on four.
We'll cut to four.
And Mary McDonnell.
Am I forgetting anyone?
-No. Who is that --
-Ben Kingsley.
-Oh, Kingsley.
-But I like that you went,
"No, just keep moving please."
If you are -- I was thinking
when you said I looked young
If you are worried about
your age and how you look,
and I have been lately,
because I turned 38,
and people no longer go like
"What?!"
You know, they go,
"Oh, yeah. Okay."
you should get a coat,
get a coat and the glasses
-Yeah.
-And people aren't going to be
like, "How old are you?"
You know?
They're going to be like, "Wha
-- What led you to this?
What do you do?" Anyway...
-That's good advice.
-I have a lot of good advice
-So we don't have an audience.
And I feel like
they're different
kind of questions to ask.
So I got a question for yo
that I was thinking, watchin
you host the fourth time.
You're an excellent "SNL" host
Four excellent episodes.
-That's very nice of you to say.
-I worked for you then,
worked with you then
when we were...
-Yeah.
-...writers on the show.
-You did not work for me.
I very much worked for you
-But you auditioned
and were hired as a writer
-August 7, 2008.
You had a long, fruitful run
as a writer on the show.
-Yeah.
-And yet now you've hosted
more than any of the cast
members from that era.
Do you feel like Loren
at some point has to come to you
and say "We got it wrong?"
-Oh, in not casting me?
-Yeah.
-Um....
No.
No, no, no.
Uh, no.
Um, because the cast
was Bill Hader,
Will Forte, Jason Sudeikis -
I'm just talking about
the males, my "competition."
There were a lot of people
that looked like me.
There were a lot of white guys
there were a lot of white
brunettes.
And Fred, you know --
-That's how I describe you
when people say "How would you
describe John's comedy?"
-He's funny.
He's a white brunette.
And I like the use
of "brunette" in general.
You don't hear it enough.
Blonde is thrown around,
but brunette --
No, like, there --
I could not do
what Fred Armisen does.
what Bill Hader does.
I could not do
what Andy Samberg does.
No one can do what
Will Forte does.
-Yeah.
-And if more people could,
you know,
they'd put a stop to it.
[ Laughter ]
That cast was so good.
The casts are so good.
I never once thought I should be
in the cast, you know?
-Yeah.
-It felt like when I would write
for Bill, it was like writin
for, like, Jimi Hendrix.
It was like I write the note
and he lights the guitar
on fire, or whatever Jimi
Hendrix did.
[ Laughter ]
But I thought I could do
"Update,"
but you were doing "Update."
-Yeah.
-And I liked you so much,
I thought it would be rude
if I made a --
if I made, like, a super har
ugly press for it.
-Yeah.
-The fourth season
of "Big Mouth"...
-Yes.
-...is coming to Netflix
later this year.
-The reason I'm here.
And we've run out of time
to talk about it,
but it's great and everybody
should watch it.
-"Big Mouth's" fourth season
is coming soon,
and we were so thrilled
that the amazing Maya Rudolp
won an Emmy this year...
-Amazing.
-...for playing
the Hormone Monstress.
When the third season ended,
my character Andrew
and Nick Kroll's character
Nick,
he gets to be Nick,
were in dire straits.
They were in a fight.
So we'll see where that picks up
in the fourth season.
But while we were on break, to
see Maya get that was fantastic.
-You guys might see an edi
somewhere in here.
John and I had a very long
conversation.
And the whole of it
will be online,
but due to time constraints,
this is what you're seeing now
-Yes.
You're seeing the very --
the heavily censored,
compromised version.
Go online for the full
discussion
where we reveal everything
Or rather discuss the same
things,
but go on too long about it.
-That's right.
We'll be right back.
-Wait. I should have --
I mean, I should have
the last word if I'm dressed
like this.
-Yeah, sure.
-Which camera?
-Just right over there.
-Which one?
-One.
-Oh.
So you say the penultimate
-Okay. The fourth season
of "Big Mouth"
is coming to Netflix
later this year.
We'll be right back with
NBC's Kristen Welker.
-And remember,
always trust your gut.
-[ Chuckles ]